what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some updates for
release dates for not only the MCU but a
release date update and a movie update
in general about the third spider-verse
film Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
Spider-Man into the spider-verse and
Spider-Man across the spider-verse were
both massive successes so it's no
surprise that fans are dying to know
when they are going to be getting the
next movie especially since across the
spider-verse left us on a pretty big
Cliffhanger across the spider verse is a
part 1 and part 2 film with across the
spider verse being the first part and
Beyond the spiderverse the second and
one of the voice actors for one of these
Spider-Man characters in the film has
recently spoken up talking about when to
expect the film and what all has to
happen in order for the film to be
completed not just completed but be
excellent be an excellent film that is
the same quality as the other two films
or even better originally the film was
supposed to come out 10 months after
across the spider-verse came out but
there's been a lot of talk about delays
recently including from people who
actually work on the film some have
stated there's no way the film is going
to release in 10 months but we have a
really good update today that we'll go
over we're also going to be talking
about some unfortunate Marvel delays
that are going to be happening in Phase
5. right now of course the writers and
actor strikes are happening and sadly we
knew that because of this we were
probably going to experience some delays
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and it
looks like that is unfortunately going
to be happening so we'll break it all
down in this video and if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so first let's start off with the
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
update from Jake Johnson who of course
plays Peter B Parker in the spider-verse
movies he talks about how we might
unfold fortunately get some delays
however it's for a very good reason when
asked about beyond the spider verse in
an interview with comicbook.com this is
what he said in regards to the March
2024 release date here's what I can
promise and I said it about the second
one when we were in the middle of it
Phil Lord Chris Miller everybody The
Producers on this the directors they're
going to bring in what they did on the
first one is all the directors became
executive producers so they just kept
adding to it what I can promise is they
are not going to stop until it's
excellent so right away that's just an
incredible statement right there they're
not going to stop working on this film
until it's an excellent film the first
two were incredible and this one's going
to be no exception to that this film has
to be incredible as well and that is
typically an extremely hard thing to do
sequels are really hard to make better
than their Originals or at least be of
the same quality but based off of what
Jake Johnson just said it sounds like
everybody is fully involved and will not
settle for anything less than excellent
now he goes on to continue to talk about
what it takes to make it excellent in
that release date he says and if that
means it takes a little bit longer that
means it's even bigger if that means
it's longer they don't play by anybody's
rules they work really hard as actors in
it we're always shocked that we get
called in to record on this last one I
think it was a month before it screened
where we could not believe we were still
recording so they're not going to quit
until it's great I have nothing but
faith in them but in terms of giving
anything away about the story I can't do
it so this is great to hear they really
do work on the film until they feel like
it's amazing like it's excellent now
unfortunately Jake Johnson hints that
there might be some delays he States and
if that means it takes a little bit
longer what he means is we have to make
this film excellent that might mean that
it's going to take a little bit longer
for the film to release it might not hit
that March release date but if that
means the movie is even better than it
was going to be if it hit that original
release date I think a lot of fans will
be okay with that unfortunately this
isn't the first time that we've heard
about possible delays for Spider-Man
beyond the spider-verse it was said that
they were supposed to work on both films
across the spider-verse and Beyond the
spiderverse at the same time however we
learned that that exactly wasn't the
case Haley Steinfeld who plays Gwen
Stacy noted back in June that she hadn't
recorded any of her material for the
next movie this was the first sign that
at least the actors did not work on them
at the same time meaning that the movie
very well could get delayed if the VFX
and the animation and the story
basically everything you need before you
do the voice recordings weren't yet
completed also in an article by vulture
it was reported that many of the VFX
artists said that it was very harsh
working conditions to work on that
second film they described it as
demanding and unsustainable conditions
for the film's VFX artists and they said
that there was a lot of revisionism
meaning a lot of changes would happen
which means a lot of Demands for the
artist and according to this article by
vulture approximately a hundred artists
left the project so this was another
sign that unfortunately the film might
be a little bit behind however Jake
Johnson seems to be pretty optimistic
about it and pretty sure that they're
not going to release this film unless it
is excellent and he didn't speak like he
thought that the film was going to be
delayed by a lot his exact words were a
little longer so although beyond the
spider-verse might not hit that March
2024 release date let's hope it's not
delayed a year pushed back to 2025.
hopefully some work did get done while
they were also working on across the
spider-verse and the delays won't be
that bad so we can get back to watching
these awesome Spider-Man characters on
screen and if you would like to dive
deeper into the comics and learn more be
sure to check out my buddies at
comicbookdirect.com they have created a
website and company that makes comic
book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door or you can get one-off
Comics or you can sign up for an entire
run and get a pretty big discount if you
do so and they'll ship the latest issue
right to your door each week they have
the latest from Marvel if you're trying
to keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now unfortunately like I
mentioned we could have some Marvel
Phase 5 delays and one of those delays
could be Deadpool 3. now recently
Deadpool 3's release date was actually
moved up several months so this delay
might just push it back to its original
release date that it had that's kind of
the good news if this does get delayed
it should only be delayed just a few
months now this report is coming from
Puck's newsletter that states Deadpool 3
could potentially suffer a delay if the
SAG after strikes aren't resolved and
the studios don't come to an agreement
with the actors sometime soon in the
newsletter it was stated that Deadpool 3
can afford to have the production halted
for around a month if it's halted for
more than a month Unfortunately they are
going to have to push back that March
3rd release date now production is
halted right now they are currently not
working on Deadpool 3 so let's hope that
the strike comes to an end pretty soon
the studios and the SAG after and the
other organizations can come to an
agreement beforehand and thanks get back
on track and we don't really suffer any
delays but if that doesn't happen like I
said it shouldn't be that big of a delay
we're talking months here not a year but
also unfortunately what we've heard is
that the Thunderbolts are probably going
to get delayed as well and this is kind
of not related to the strike the strike
doesn't help of course but Insider
Charles Murphy stated this recently even
pre-sag strike I heard the chances of
thunderbolts making that December 2024
release date weren't good so that on top
of production delays due to the strikes
most likely means that we are going to
have a delay for the Thunderbolts film
as well hopefully the Deadpool 3 delay
and the Thunderbolts delay doesn't
really affect the rest of Phase 5 and
Phase 6 however if the strike continues
for a pretty decent time unfortunately
we should expect some delays if that
happens but of course if we hear
anything we'll be sure to do an update
on it so be sure to subscribe hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news don't forget
to give the video a like you can also
find us on patreon you can check out our
website and Discord server as well and
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof